NASCAR on NBC analysts the former champ
now retired sort of Dale Earnhardt jr.
joining us on the program
how are you jr. man I'm doing pretty
good considering sorry for being late
I'm usually on time for your show that's
sorry that's alright you got other
things to worry about there you were two
minutes late you know I know I know but
it's weird how busy I am I don't you
know we when when I'll just kind of went
down and everybody was we've been kind
of locked up in the house for about
several weeks now took it pretty
seriously from the get-go and I thought
he's gonna run out of things to do but
thanks there's a lot going on right here
pretty busy okay but you have a baby at
home another baby on the way I mean yeah
you think you're busy now you wait no I
know I know I love it I really enjoy
being a dad and you know that was that
first year was pretty tough
hey I mean I'm you know from that
perspective it's tough it's even worse
obviously for a me so I don't want to
claim too much but it was uh it's it's
it was I'm looking forward to it again
you know I mean we just kind of got I
was 2 years old and you'd think that we
would be kind of relieved that we're out
of that first year but I'm looking
forward to it again you know we've
always kind of wanted to have two kids
and you know we're just really blessed
to have this opportunity and just real
scary times to kind of be going through
this with everything else going on it's
got you know got us pretty pretty
nervous and and no non-essential visits
so we can't go to the doctor and get the
typical normal checkups that you would
get in this process so that's made us a
little concerned but obviously you know
Amy's Amy doing great and you know just
waiting for everything to get back to
normal and trying to stay healthy and
hoping you know trying to keep everybody
around us and all her family's in good
spirits and keep everything going you
gotta have patience yeah yes
with everything even when this we move
past this
just having patience when you have
children and it's the one thing that God
ever since humor and have patience and
and it'll help you get through this
because you're gonna have to in diapers
probably and just dealing with that and
your sleep and all those things you're
gonna be like and you think driving a
racecar was tough that's gonna be a you
know Sunday drive literally compared to
what you're going through but I did
enjoy the iRacing and explain explain
how this came about because this is
Denny Hamlin was great at AI racing and
I think that's how maybe you noticed him
but how did this come about the NASCAR
was gonna do AI racing well this the
software has been around for two decades
and it's a great service they offer they
offer oval oval car racing you know late
models Modifieds
legends cars about anything you can
think of three stocks any level they had
the trucks the Xfinity cars Cup cars
obviously they're even more popular on
the road course side and out and and
globally like there's so many customers
on the service overseas playing at all
hours of the night I mean this is 24
hour process there's races going off
every hour
you just you know it's just a really
great service a lot of fun 125 active
members right now sorry about that
sorry so it's growing but it's been
around a long time it has and a lot of
people you know 10 10 20 years ago when
I tell people about AI racing and how
realistic it was and how I used it to
help myself as a race car driver
you know everybody pretty much in the
industry would roll their eyes so it's
really funny now that everybody locking
tie racing trying to get Sims trying to
get on the service trying to understand
how it works trying to get comfortable
driving cars on the sim all these people
that would that would chuckle when I
would tell them years ago about it are
now diving into a headfirst but it's
been it's had a relationship with NASCAR
for a long time in a funny story I'll
tell you
so iRacing was started by dave kramer
and who is a software engineer that
develops games and John Henry owner in
Red Sox
so John Henry is a big simracing fan and
those two partnered to create iRacing
two decades ago and i put together a
meeting between iRacing and nascar right
around 2008 or so i don't remember
exactly when it was it seems like it
might have been a little later at
2010-12
but anyhow at Junior Motorsports NASCAR
comes in and I racing and comes down
from Boston they're located up there
Boston John Henry comes and so we're
sitting there and I'm telling NASCAR
about I recorded that we form a
partnership as they get involved and
John has to step out of the office
because he has to take a call because it
had a blockbuster trade who was the
player that they traded the Red Sox
traded back then it was who did who did
they acquire or who did they trade they
were trading away their best player this
huge huge player big deal yeah and this
is 2008 maybe around 2012 2010
I forget who this wasn't the Carl
Crawford deal to the Dodgers was it no
no no no no this was like bigger than
that but anyhow right in the middle of
the what I'm sure you guys could figure
it out right in the middle of the
meeting John has to get up to go talk
about this trade cause it's happening
right now and it was just a really
interesting sort of a lot of things
going on at one time but that's how long
that NASCAR and I racing have had a
relationship and so last year was this
meeting was this Manny Ramirez yeah so
that was always right yeah 2008 yeah
alright so I was right out 2008 he has
to get up at the middle of meeting to go
handle talk about this trade finalize do
whatever they do right and so I thought
that was pretty cool anyway
maybe if you knew it was Manny ramírez
it would have been cool all right you're
on a roll Your Honor I you've had
concussions anyways the the
relationships been there long time last
year NBC got on board and started
putting some of the races that happen on
I racing on TV putting it on NBC Sports
Network and there's NASCAR has an elite
series where kids and grownups across
the country sort of compete against each
other and they've been putting that and
broadcasting it on TV so it wasn't a
foreign idea or or some kind of weird
you know shot in the dark for Fox to
consider doing this they know it's been
done before they just hadn't they just
wouldn't words weren't sure if they
could get all the real world drivers to
buy in because a lot of these guys
weren't on the Finns they didn't have
the equipment the hardware so I'm gonna
be honestly it was a huge scramble in
like a week maybe maybe less to get as
many people as they could with hardware
to do it and then the commitment from
the drivers they didn't have to do it I
might have been better than Jimmie
Johnson that might be the only time I'm
a better driver than Jimmie Johnson jr.
in a very small window of time Thank You
practices then and I'm sure he's gonna
improve greatly and a lot of guys have
been practicing all week but take me to
that final lap with you and Denny Hamlin
you're leading and Hamlin who's really
good at this and a really good driver as
well what was that he he so with 30 laps
to go
I pitted four tires and then they had a
cannot a caution with 20 laps ago we had
a caution and I could have came down to
got tires and I should have but I was
like yeah it's too crazy back in the
back of crashing and I don't want to get
wrecked out so I'm done pitting wait do
you ever cruise you know I mean I I'm
sitting on we got discord and teamspeak
working with your two chat programs
where we can talk to our friends I'm
talking to my buddies like hey what do
y'all think I should do
but it's ultimately up to you and I
didn't come down to get tires in there
an advantage the tires fall off just
like I realized they get slower as you
run and there's less grip as you drive
each lap and so did he had a little bit
of a tire advantage plus he's very good
I didn't think he was going to get back
up through there like yet I never even
thought I was gonna be sitting there
with a shot to win but I'm driving the
car and taking the lead and I'm thinking
wow I might win and then here comes dent
Denny to spoil it was fun but you should
add a virtual fight well you know I
thought about you know in hindsight I
thought man I should have just took him
out or I should just ran him up the
track what's worse it could happen
looking you know but it was it was a lot
of fun is I've had a relationship with
AI racing for a real long time so I'm
glad it was an exciting experience for
everybody who was watching huge huge
boost for AI race and as a platform and
they've gotten so many new customers
since that that was pretty cool great
yeah they had a great job
hey I wanted to ask you about your
Redskins how are you feeling going into
the draft here you know are you okay
with Dwayne Haskins as your starting
quarterback for sure I mean what yeah
yes because we can take two uh yeah but
I mean you have to worry about the
injury and whether he can overcome that
and I you know I'm look I am so far
removed from it that I don't even I
nobody but the insiders really know
where to is that physically right so the
concern is that you take to a and he
doesn't ever overcome that Ajay hips or
serious deals and you know you don't see
a lot of guys come back from hip
injuries and and do well but you know if
we do if we don't draft him and it
becomes this awesome player I mean
that's just a risk you take and I'm
going to take that risk but the you know
chase Young's a gun
he's an awesome player
once-in-a-lifetime kind of there Connor
man he's like once in a once in a decade
kind of you know player to be drafted
for that position with the other guys
that we drafted on defense especially
the defense a lot over the last several
years it would just make us really tough
on the front line there did you ever
think about changing teams no no I mean
it could get a whole lot worse I'm not
even came close to considering it but
you know there's just not any other
teams out there to really appeal to me
and I've gotten so much and I've got a
Redskins fan since 81 or 82 and I'm too
invested and it is what it is so not
Carolina you never thought about maybe
switching your allegiance to Carolina
you know I just that's too close to home
good lord
I mean if imagine being a Carolina fan
and them having but you know the last
couple of decades the Redskins have had
usually living right underneath it you
need your distance not right under my
nose here you got names picked out for
the next baby well we had a boy we had a
boy's name picked out what was a
splendid day we didn't use I can tell
you that why because you're having
another girl know I don't know that oh
you don't I wait I thought your daughter
said that she was gonna all she was
going to be a big sister so you don't
know if you just had the same exact
reaction that I had that in the bowl
back Dan you got to be better than this
you've had days and weeks to see this
video and and get it like I can do true
I could you fall for it okay wait I did
okay
I mean yeah we both fell for that Oh see
see now I don't feel so bad but yeah I
walk in and she's got this shirt that
says big sister or something on there I
don't know what it said sometimes sister
I'm like how you know it's a girl and it
took me a second to think like of course
she doesn't know it's a girl we don't
know what it is
I was the sister you know what I'm
thinking
Trey Earnhardt
I mean I've got some friends that are
trade so I don't want same thing oh okay
let's how about just three say what
three the number three yeah just the car
numbers agree just call no not we've got
a name it's gonna be fine if it's a boy
now if it's a girl
that was really hard - that was hard too
hard to figure out well you could call
her
it's therisa I like to do the numbers
what Paulie Dale all the NASCAR drivers
refer to each other like you know the 48
car the 24 car named your son three the
three is got to take out the garbage
no all right so you have a boy's name
picked out already
yeah and and you you don't have a girl's
name picked out that took us the entire
nine months when when I was you know in
Amy's little belly there it took us
forever to figure out a girl's name and
Amy did it I had no I had no assistance
or help in that book I imagine the it'll
be tough to figure out another girl's
name that we like I don't know why that
was just tough that was just a real
challenge are you racing this weekend i
racing you know when so so so we did
that race last week at fox big success
and now they want to do it every week
right and and that's great and the fans
can enjoy it and they're a lot more
drivers are getting involved I know that
Truex is trying to get going
Harvick's coming in you know there's
there's you won't be surprised to see
Tony Stewart pop in LA guys are jumping
on that weren't there last week so this
thing's are going to keep going each
week I'm not I'm not made like a hard
commitment to run every single race I
just kind of have to wait until Sunday
and see what's going on in my house I'm
kind of a game-time decision but I plan
on racing but I mean if something's
going on and I can't physically do it
you know there's
there's other things going on around
here that need my attention I have to do
those boom yeah that's good mmm that's
good you got you got other priorities
there Congrats again on baby number two
and and once again if you want to take
three I don't want any credit and if
it's a girl it's Teresa I'm okay with
that as well I'm sure Amy will be very
happy to hear my suggestions and I'm
never gonna tell her about this oh
you're not no she's not needed here oh
okay that's probably best
we keep it between us hey great to talk
to you again jr. thank you
hi guys take care yourself okay that's
Dale jr. former NASCAR driver may be
current NASCAR iracing.com